[Music]
cats are sassy purr machines that
secretly love their human companions of
course some cats do forget how to cat
from time to time usually because cats
simply do not give a care if you love
cats as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
thumbs up today we're showing you 20
cats who don't know how to catch
mistakes were made this cat looks like
he knows he made a mistake
his shame is apparent and his widened
eyes he basically looks like he's given
up we're not sure what happened here
maybe he was walking along the back of
the couch when he slipped and fell maybe
he just sleeps like that though we won't
touch dinner time
ketchup mustard a bag of chips a hot dog
bun filled with a rap stick of butter no
wonder that cat is screaming none of
that equals a proper meal he probably
thought he was going to get hot dog only
to be sorely disappointed by that
strange food combination either way cats
don't belong at the dinner table pool
party apparently this cat got caught up
in the excitement of a pool party he was
so amped over the prospect of Marco Polo
and barbecue that he forgot one very
important fact
cats loathed water a couple of burgers
and lemonade's deep into the pool party
celebrations and mittens made the
mistake of his life
Modern Art the met has clearly lowered
their standards by letting this art
piece grace their gallery we understand
the novelty of Salem the cat is an
artist for the obviously lacks classical
training a clothes hanger around the
artists neck is not fine art no matter
how adorable the artist is you should
probably just stick to taking naps in
the Sun
feline foliage when attempting to grow a
cat tree
you must always look for a proper
container clear glass containers will
allow a lot of sunlight to filter in
helping your cat sprout appropriately
make sure to seek your kitten
comfortably in the bottom of your
preferred glass jar do not water and
leave plenty of ventilation gravity cats
are typically pretty graceful when
they're not they don't seem to care what
humans think of them either this cat is
all out of cares or this is a rare photo
of a cat in outer space we're kind of
hoping it's an optical illusion if it's
not this cat has some impressive skills
look at him defying gravity like that
hot dog no one bothered to tell this cat
that he can't be a hot dog
regardless he doesn't care what you
think he's leaving the cat life behind
catnip and all to explore what if life
thing was stuffed into a hot dog bun
sadly he could not find a large enough
fun so couch cushions had to suffice
groceries it's pretty much a given that
cats aren't groceries they shouldn't be
stored in the vegetable crisper and they
certainly shouldn't be placed in plastic
bags this cat however seems to have
confused himself with a bag of groceries
we know cats love being inside
containers so he probably crawled in
there himself
that's not safe kitty stand up will the
real slim kitty please stand up cats are
definitely skilled acrobats but they're
supposed to use all four of their legs
this little guy is clearly confused by
something and trying to get a better
look he may not know how to cat properly
but he sure is cute with his pudgy belly
cat and mouse we think this cat is a tad
bit confused cats are supposed to chase
mice obviously but that's the wrong kind
of mouse perhaps this feel I needed to
get a job to pay for more candy litter
wait he has to be ordering catnip and
canned salmon on Amazon just look at him
licking his lips potty training teaching
a new kitten to use a litter box is a
lot of work it would be so much easier
if they could just learn to use the
toilet this Kitty doesn't know he's
supposed to use a litter box maybe he's
just trying to help his owner out with
potty training duty we're pretty sure
he's stuck yoga we're sure you've heard
of downward-facing dog but how about the
confused Kitty okay so more than likely
this little kitten fell asleep on the
job
we all know how kittens spend
- their time sleeping so that wouldn't
be surprising then again hopefully the
little guy didn't trip and fall please
be careful kittens couch potato tiger is
obviously harboring some deep-seated
resentment he's probably a little upset
over his new haircut his belly has to be
cold that lion tail look isn't doing him
any favors if he has to be cold he's
going to make sure his owners have to
stare at his shame we don't blame him
shake it off have you ever tripped in a
room full of people and were forced to
play it off that's precisely what's
happening here the black cat was
probably being a normal cat wandering
across the room when he suddenly bit the
desk
he had to pretend to perform an
interpretive dance before his friend
could make fun of him plastic forget
feeling like a plastic bag have you ever
felt like a plastic water bottle we have
a feeling that this cat has okay so he
probably saw a box says cats are prone
to do and then decided to crawl inside
it mistakes were definitely made and he
knows it just look at that expression on
his face spider cat okay so this isn't
necessarily a cat failing at being a cat
cats can climb right they love to climb
trees and get stuck in them it's what
keeps small-town fire departments in
business after all we don't think that
cats should be able to cling to the side
of a flat wall dot cat is clearly up to
no good pretty flower
we're not sure what grocery store this
person is shopping at but they
definitely need to ask for a refund
that's not flower that's a cat stuffed
into a container for flower all right so
the cat probably loves to be in small
containers like most cats - it is pretty
funny that he's the same color as flower
karate-kick
cats love a good fight and it looks like
this kitty is practicing his moves
rather than using his front claws he's
opting for a swift roundhouse kick with
skills like that he can take out any
enemy more than likely he got something
stuck to his foot we're going to pretend
he's practicing his sparring yummy wood
dogs are most notable for their
willingness to eat basically anything
cats tend to be a little more finicky
though this cat however seems to be the
exception
apparently the wood cabinet is just too
tasty to pass up he is certainly chowing
down hopefully his owners can stop him
before he eat the drywall
fierce predator felines are well known
for preying upon rodents and birds this
cat clearly didn't get the memo though
the look on his face says his patience
is wearing thin
but clearly those little rodents adore
him even if they're only using him for
warmth oh who are we kidding we hope
they all grow up to be best friends
that's it for twenty cats who don't know
how to cat it if you like this video be
sure to hit that like button and
subscribe for more great content from
the things thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]